[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing severus snape draco malfoy
the killing of albus damodar and one
unbreakable vow
the unbreakable vow is a binding magical
contract that connects
two parties the purpose is simple it is
to bind a fellow which a wizard
to a promise the participants stand
opposite each other
and clasp each other's right hands while
a third party acts like a sort of
mediator or witness and places the tip
of their wand
onto the hands of the two participants
the mediator acts almost like a minister
and will begin to state conditions or
responsibilities
related to the vow after stating each
condition of the vow
the participant who is to uphold said
responsibilities must agree to them
one by one in the year 1996 during the
opening chapters of the half-blood
prince
narcissa malfoy asks snape to make one
of these unbreakable vows
and it is at this time that he vows to
protect draco
help him with his task and even finish
it himself should draco fail
the conditions of this vow were to
protect malfoy from harm
while he attempted to perform the task
that voldemort had asked him to perform
kill albus dumbledore snape also agreed
to complete the task that malfoy was
assigned
in the event that malfoy was unable this
is quite the responsibility for snape to
take on
particularly as if you're unable to
honor the promise that you've made with
the unbreakable vow
you will die death is the ultimate
consequence
and that is of course white is deemed
unbreakable you are stuck with what
you've promised until you either
act on said promise or die from what we
know there is no other way of getting
out
of an unbreakable vow but one thing that
i've always wondered is
why would snape willingly agree to enter
an unbreakable vow with narcissa
snape had been an effective double agent
for many years and both sides felt
they had an ally in snape so what did he
have to prove
first of all it's worth mentioning that
bellatrix didn't completely trust him
brothertrix was voldemort's most loyal
death eater and companion
and because she harboured feelings for
voldemort she was particularly
protective of him and his cause
this meant that snape's wish-washy
history left bellatrix unconvinced of
snape's motivations
when narcissa and bellatrix introduced
the idea of an unbreakable vow to snape
bellatrix was unconvinced that snape
would enter it willingly
she was trying to prove that snape
wasn't an ally to the death eaters
and this would be the ultimate test
would snape agree to kill
albus dumbledore so the first reason
that snape entered the vow
was just to disprove bellatrix's
allegations the second reason that snape
agreed to enter the vow was that he was
always going to be the one to kill
dumbledore
anyway though the task was assigned to
draco voldemort never actually expected
draco to be able to complete the task
this was his way of punishing lucius for
his failures
this meant that the task would
inevitably always fall on snape to
complete
voldemort knew that draco would fail in
addition to this
in order to appease dumbledore and
protect draco's soul snape agreed to
kill the hogwarts headmaster himself
this would simultaneously complete the
unbreakable vow that he had entered
as well as protect young draco's soul so
there you have it
despite snape's impressive levels of
power and ability to act as an effective
double agent
he did ultimately need to enter this
unbreakable vow
both to prove his loyalty and to protect
draco had dumbledore not already been
ill
then the whole harry potter story would
have been remarkably different and i'm
sure that if that were the case
snape would have never agreed to commit
such an act all he agreed to do
was kill an old dying wizard that was
going to die anyway
to protect a young boy and that's it for
this video
if you enjoy the content please like the
video and subscribe to the channel
until next time your wizard howdy
[Music]
you